So what do you want? Oh my god, I'm a slut. I wear a bunch of different stuff. I've never worn the same perfume two days in a row. This is Rachel Sime. She's a staff writer for The New Yorker and one of the most genuinely glamorous people I have ever met. So she always smells like some perfume or another.
所以你想要什么？天哪，我真是一个放荡的女人。我用各种各样的东西。我从来没有连续两天用过同一种香水。这是蕾切尔·西姆（Rachel Sime）。她是《纽约客》的特约撰稿人，也是我见过真正最有魅力的人之一。所以她总是散发着这样或那样的香水味。
I love like deor poison. And I use NIE's and I love wearing number five in the highest concentration as the oil. And I like tuberose and I love gardenia and I love it to be like a cloud of that around you. I just love it. I was the opposite of Rachel. I didn't really get perfume.
我喜欢像迪奥毒药（Dior Poison）这样的香水。我用Kiehl's，我喜欢浓度最高、作为精油的香奈儿5号。我喜欢晚香玉，我喜欢栀子花，我喜欢你周围环绕着这样的一团香气。我就是喜欢。我跟蕾切尔完全相反。我其实不太懂香水。
I would spritz some on at the airport sometimes, but mostly I just found it all smelled perfume-y. I don't think I can smell. On paper, everything just smells like chemicals to me. Yeah, well, it needs a moment to dry down. I wanted to figure out what I was missing. So I asked Rachel to take me perfume shopping at Sephora, hence the annoying pop music you hear in the background.
我有时会在机场喷一点，但大部分时候我只觉得它们闻起来都有一股“香水味”。我觉得我闻不到。在纸面上，对我来说一切都只是化学品的气味。好吧，它需要一点时间来挥发。我想弄清楚我错过了什么。于是我请蕾切尔带我去丝芙兰买香水，因此你能听到背景里讨厌的流行音乐。
I like, I love this set. It's so delicious. Oh, it's cut. I'm like, I can't describe it. It's too gross. That's so delicious. Oh, I'm like, I have to describe it. I'm like, oh, it's too gross. That's too gross, but that's sour. And then there's a little ginger on the top. Whatever Rachel was experiencing, I wasn't getting it.
我喜欢，我超喜欢这套。太美妙了。哦，断了。我觉得，我无法描述。太恶心了。太美妙了。哦，我觉得我必须描述一下。我说，哦，这太恶心了。这太恶心了，但那是酸的。然后顶部有一点生姜。不管蕾切尔在体验什么，我可一点都没体会到。
It was like I was trying to fudge my way through a wine tasting by being like, oh yeah, this one has overtones of grape. Too sweet. I guess it just smells chemical eating. It smells like clean,ations, you know? Yeah. I thought perfume was a kind of snake oil,
这就像我在葡萄酒品鉴会上滥竽充数，假装说：“哦，对了，这款有葡萄的余味。”太甜了。我猜它只是闻起来有化学制品的感觉。它闻起来像干净的康乃馨，你知道吗？是的。我以为香水是一种江湖骗术，
but basically the only thing separating one perfume from another was the design of the bottle and the name of the brand. I thought perfume was just a way for big fashion labels to make money, which it absolutely is. Like Chanel makes a ton of money from fragrance, Dior, the places where basically people can't always afford the thing, but they can afford the perfume. It's like people's gateway drug to get into the branding. And so I was ready to make a story that would be like,
但基本上，区分一款香水和另一款香水的唯一东西就是瓶子的设计和品牌的名称。我以为香水只是大牌时尚公司赚钱的一种方式，事实也确实如此。就像香奈儿通过香水赚了海量的钱，迪奥也是，这些地方基本上人们不一定总买得起他们的衣服，但买得起香水。这就像是人们进入品牌世界的入门毒品。所以我当时准备做一个报道，内容大概是：
wake up people, perfume is a ruse. You're getting fleeced for a name and the packaging. You know, I really admire and think a lot about the artistry behind perfumes when they're made, even any of these designer perfumes. This is what Rachel knew that I had yet to find out. Perfume is a key to a whole other dimension that we've all collectively denied and forgotten.
醒醒吧各位，香水是个骗局。你们的钱全被一个名字和包装给骗走了。你知道的，当香水被制造出来时，我真的很崇拜并深思其背后的艺术性，哪怕是任何这些设计师香水。这就是蕾切尔知道而我还没发现的事情：香水是一把通往另一个维度的钥匙，而这个维度一直被我们集体否定和遗忘了。
Articles of interest. The show about what we wear. Season 2. People don't realize it's fantasy. It's always this thing that you have to work extra hard to get. Mmm, and that's so good. No one dresses like a king anymore. How do you make money?
感兴趣的物件。关于我们穿什么的节目。第二季。人们没有意识到这是一种幻想。这总是一种你需要付出额外努力才能得到的东西。嗯，这太棒了。现在没有人像国王那样穿衣服了。你们是怎么赚钱的？
That's how we make money, love. There are lots of things that we take for granted that would once have been considered luxuries. If someone forced you to surrender one of your five senses, you'd probably handily give up your sense of smell. I mean, I would. We talk about how foods are umami or spicy or how music can be soothing or energizing or cacophonous, but with scent, we don't really analyze it with a lot of nuance. The question is usually black or white. Do you like the scent
我们就是这样赚钱的，亲爱的。有很多我们视为理所当然的事情，曾经都被认为是奢侈品。如果有人强迫你放弃五感中的一种，你可能会顺手放弃你的嗅觉。我是说，我会的。我们讨论食物是鲜美的还是辛辣的，或者音乐如何舒缓、充满活力或刺耳，但对于气味，我们并没有用太多的细微差别去分析它。这个问题通常是非黑即白的。你喜欢这个气味
or not? The smells good, the smells bad. We just don't have a lot of tools to analyze smells, linguistically or scientifically. In fact, there is no way to assess the volume of a scent. There are no instruments that can measure odor levels. We have instruments that can measure the chemicals that are in an odor plume, but that doesn't translate into, at least not at the present time, into what the odor experience is for any individual.
还是不喜欢？闻起来香，闻起来臭。我们在语言上或科学上确实没有很多工具来分析气味。事实上，没有办法评估气味的强度。没有任何仪器可以测量气味水平。我们有可以测量气味羽流中化学物质的仪器，但这并不能转化为——至少目前不能——转化为任何个人的气味体验。
Hamill Adolten is a senior scientist at the Monel Chemical Senses Center in Philadelphia. But when I talked to her, she was not in Philly. She was talking to me from a conference room in Chicago. I'm here for a deposition. I do expert witness work from time to time, and this is notercase involving people complaining around bland silly. In legal cases involving smells,
哈米尔·阿多尔滕（Hamill Adolten）是费城莫内尔化学感官中心的高级科学家。但当我采访她时，她不在费城。她是在芝加哥的一个会议室里跟我通话的。我来这里是为了作证。我有时会做专家证人工作，这不是一个涉及人们抱怨平淡气味的案件。在涉及气味的法律案件中，
they have to hire professional noses to make very subjective calls. And it's not like Pamela is a superhuman. Generally, people are pretty good at smelling. Much better than we think we are. We can smell at things when there's one or two parts of a fragrance material in a billion parts of air, which is really, really tiny. So we're more sensitive than we believe that dogs may be sensitive to a range of compounds, but humans have much more sensitivity to a much more diverse set of chemicals in the environment. But we don't use scent the way dogs and other animals do.
他们必须聘请专业调香师来做出非常主观的判断。这并不是说帕梅拉（Pamela）是什么超人。总的来说，人们的嗅觉相当不错。比我们想象的要好得多。当空气中有十亿分之一或二的香水原料时，我们就能闻到，这真的是非常非常微量。所以我们比想象的更敏感，狗可能对一系列化合物敏感，但人类对环境中更多样化的化学物质具有更高的敏感度。但我们不像狗和其他动物那样使用嗅觉。
In part, it's because we're bipedal. Our noses, quite simply, evolved to be farther away from the earth. We're now at four to five to six feet above the ground, so we're smelling different things, right? We're not smelling things as we were when we were loathing around on all fours. Yet still, on occasion, we'll lift our noses to the air and take a sniff. It's just that more often than not, we pay attention to smells that present a threat. Spoiled foods, rot, death, mold, if there's a fire or a gas leak. Farts.
部分原因是因为我们是双足行走的。很简单，我们的鼻子进化得离地面更远了。我们现在离地面有四到五到六英尺高，所以我们闻到的东西不同了，对吧？我们不再像以前四肢着地爬行时那样闻东西了。然而有时，我们还是会把鼻子抬向空中吸气。只是更多时候，我们关注的是那些表现出威胁的气味。变质的食物、腐烂、死亡、发霉，如果有火灾或煤气泄漏。屁。
And so we learn that, you know, we want to stay away from those kind of voters. We've come to associate scent with something primal and unpleasant. If you ask, hey, do I smell? The collective assumption is that that's a bad thing. We want to avoid smells and smelling, and this mentality goes back to a number of philosophers in the West, from Plato to Aristotle to Kant, who derided our sense of smell as base and secondary, or really like quenery. Historically, it has been the least respected of our senses. And so a lot of folks just try to ignore it.
于是我们了解到，你知道的，我们要远离那种气味。我们已经把气味与某种原始而不愉快的东西联系在一起。如果你问，“嘿，我身上有味道吗？”，大家的共同假设是那是一件坏事。我们想要避开气味和嗅觉，这种心态可以追溯到西方的一批哲学家，从柏拉图到亚里士多德再到康德，他们嘲笑我们的嗅觉是低级和次要的，甚至真的是微不足道的。历史上，它是最不受尊重的感官。所以很多人干脆试图忽视它。
But I think as a species, we have discounted that we really can smell a lot of chemicals advancing retrieval concentration. So we have the capacity to smell things in the parts per billions, but we lack the capacity to talk about them. So much of learning to smell comes from learning how to describe smells. So I was at a party.
但我认为作为一个物种，我们低估了我们其实能够闻到大量处于浓度检索中的化学物质。所以我们有能力闻到十亿分之几的东西，但我们缺乏谈论它们的能力。学习闻香很大程度上来自于学习如何描述气味。所以当时我在一个派对上。
A woman came in who was hugging everybody and she smelled really good and a number of people told her that she smelled good. And I said, okay, I can tell you that she's wearing this particular brand and it's from this many years ago and the reason that she smells cozy and snug is because it's got a lot of ironones in it, and she smells sort of like auras, which is the aged root of the Florentine iris flower, and it's got a sort of a powdery feeling,
一个女人走进来拥抱了每个人，她闻起来真的很香，很多人告诉她她闻起来很香。我说，好吧，我可以告诉你她喷的是这个特定的品牌，这是多年前出的，她闻起来之所以让人感到舒适和惬意，是因为里面有很多鸢尾酮（ironones），她闻起来有点像鸢尾花，也就是佛罗伦萨鸢尾花陈化的根，并且有一种类似粉末的感觉，
so she smells like a hug. And everyone's looking at me and I was like, I'm not smelling anymore than you are. I just have the words to tell you what the brand is when it came out and what's in it. Miranda Gordon is the vice president of marketing at MAN. MAN is a fragrance company, because the lion's share
所以她闻起来就像一个拥抱。每个人都看着我，我说：我的嗅觉没有比你们灵敏。我只是有词汇来告诉你们这是什么品牌、它是什么时候问世的以及里面有什么成分。米兰达·戈登（Miranda Gordon）是曼恩（MAN）公司的营销副总裁。曼恩是一家香水公司，因为每年推出的成百上千款设计师香水中，绝大部分
of the hundreds and hundreds of designer perfumes that come out each year are made by the same dozen or so companies. MAN has made perfumes for banana public and our money and a ton of sense for really widespread popular brands you definitely know, like, I'm the ****. And when our likes talk about so don't mention those.
都是由这十来家公司制造的。曼恩曾为香蕉共和国（Banana Republic）以及诸如此类的品牌制作过香水，还有大量你绝对知道的广受欢迎的大众品牌，比如，我是说****。当我们的喜好谈及时，所以别提那些了。
For some brands, it's a dirty secret that they contract out their sense to other companies. But I don't think there should be any shame in it. Because sure, most of us have the potential to get really good at smelling, but actually designing a perfume is something entirely different. It's like composing a piece of music
对某些品牌来说，他们将气味外包给其他公司是一个不可告人的秘密。但我认为这没什么好羞耻的。因为当然，我们大多数人都有可能变得非常擅长闻香，但实际设计一款香水则是完全不同的事情。这就像创作一首音乐
or choreographing a dance. It is an art, and the professionals make it look easy. Let's start simply. Some perfume ingredients can be very straightforward. Like if you're trying to use a citrus scent, that's pretty easy to get. That scent is extracted from the peel of the fruit with cold pressing. At the same rate, we make olive oil. We can make grapefruit oil or lemon oil or lime oil or mandarin oil. But there are a lot of sense that you can't just get. You can't just press the oil of a mango,
或编排一支舞蹈。这是一门艺术，而专业人士让它看起来很简单。让我们从简单的开始。有些香水成分可以非常直接。比如如果你想用柑橘香，那很容易得到。这种香气是通过冷压从水果皮中提取的。就像我们制作橄榄油一样。我们可以制作葡萄柚油、柠檬油、青柠油或橘子油。但有很多气味是你无法直接得到的。你不能直接压榨芒果的油，
or a strawberry, or a pear, or an apple. Like if you pressed an apple peel, you wouldn't get apple oil, you would get apple juice, which is not very fragrant, and you wouldn't want to dab that on yourself. So there are many, many sense that perfumers have to build. Molecule by molecule. In a laboratory.
或者草莓、梨或苹果。就像如果你压榨苹果皮，你不会得到苹果汁（应为苹果油，译者按原文直译：苹果油），你会得到苹果汁，它不是很香，你也不会想把它拍在自己身上。所以有非常非常多的气味是调香师必须构建的。分子接分子。在实验室里。
There are chemicals that have an apple odor to them. Geno Percontino is one of the perfumers at mine. If he wants to make an apple scent, he will gather a bunch of smells together, what some perfumers call notes. Combining and mixing those notes to get an authentic apple smell. And a group of notes makes an accord. An accord is a group of ingredients that's usually less than 10 ingredients, a two, try to emulate a specific thing.
有些化学物质带有苹果气味。吉诺·佩尔孔蒂诺（Gino Percontino）是曼恩公司的调香师之一。如果他想制作苹果香，他会收集一堆气味，也就是调香师所说的“香调”（notes）。将这些香调结合并混合，以获得正宗的苹果香。一组香调就构成了一个“香协”（accord）。香协是一组通常少于10种成分的原料，旨在模仿特定的事物。
And there's no one set apple accord. less than 10 ingredients, and two try to emulate a specific thing. And there's no one set Apple accord. Every perfumer has their own way to make it. Think of it like, Gino is painting a picture of an apple. It could be realistic, it could be impressionistic, it could be cartoonish, the apple could be slightly fermented, it could be a yellow apple or a green apple, it could be in a tree, it could be in a pie.
而且没有单一固定的苹果香协。少于10种成分，并且试图模仿特定的事物。而且没有单一固定的苹果香协。每个调香师都有自己独特的制作方法。把它想象成：吉诺正在画一幅苹果的画。它可以是写实的，可以是印象派的，可以是卡通的，苹果可以稍微发酵，可以是黄苹果或绿苹果，它可以在树上，也可以在馅饼里。
Listen to how Gino renders a fig, which is another one of those cents you have to build note by note. Fig is always fun for me because I often work from some of my best coconut, just coconut. So I'm not talking about like peanut collada with pineapple and all that. Just the creamy kind of coconut, if you dial it back
听听吉诺是如何展现无花果的，这也是那些你需要逐个音符（香调）构建的气味之一。无花果对我的乐趣总是很多，因为我经常从我最好的椰子味中提取，仅仅是椰子。所以这不是指带有菠萝之类的椰林飘香（pina colada）。只是那种带有奶油味的椰子，如果你把它调淡一点，
and put more pulp into it, a little more juiciness into it, a little more green with some extra woods, because you want that stemmy element of it, and then you've turned a coconut into a fig. And that's the part that's technically impressive, but making a perfume is not just about rendering a good believable fig.
并在其中加入更多的果肉，多一点多汁感，多一点绿意和一些额外的木香，因为你想要那种带梗的元素，然后你就把椰子变成了无花果。这就是技术上令人印象深刻的部分，但制作香水不仅仅是呈现一个好的、逼真的无花果。
It's then using that fig in a way that's interesting and new. So, Gino could situate the fig in a scent that's smoky and leathery, or something powdery and floral, or something lush and green, or include an ingredient that I would have never considered. My favorite ingredient is szechuan pepper. Yeah, szechuan pepper. Yeah, szechuan pepper. It's kind of citrusy. It has a citrusy element.
然后是以一种有趣且崭新的方式使用这个无花果。所以，吉诺可以将无花果置于一种烟熏和皮革味的香气中，或者某种粉状和花香的香气中，或者某种浓郁和绿意的香气中，或者加入一种我绝不会考虑的成分。我最喜欢的成分是四川花椒。是的，四川花椒。是的，四川花椒。它有点像柑橘。它带有柑橘的元素。
It has an aromatic element. It has a little spicy element. There's a virtuosity in professional perfume. That's the difference between, say, an essential oil from a health food store and a perfume. It's the difference between the pleasure of a single ripe peach and the pleasure of an exquisitely executed risotto. Professional perfume is artistry and intuition and a lot of hard science
它带有芳香的元素。它带有一点辛辣的元素。专业调香中存在着一种精湛的技艺。这就是健康食品店的精油与香水之间的区别。这就像是一个单颗成熟桃子的乐趣与一份精美绝伦的意大利烩饭的乐趣之间的区别。专业的香水制作是艺术、直觉和大量硬核科学的结合，
because some combinations just don't work on a molecular level. If you don't know what you're doing and you take the smell of black current and the smell of rhubarb and you put it together in a test tube, things are going to interact the molecular level and it's going to smell like the cat pissed on your weed. In Mons Laboratory in Midtown Manhattan, perfumers and technicians were busily mixing drops from
因为某些组合在分子层面上根本行不通。如果你不知道自己在做什么，把黑醋栗的味道和大黄的味道放在试管里混合在一起，这些东西会在分子层面上相互作用，闻起来就会像猫尿在了你的杂草上。在曼恩位于曼哈顿中城的实验室里，调香师和技术人员正忙着将
a selection of hundreds and hundreds of notes. The smell of the laboratory was incredible. It wasn't like a perfume counter in a department store. That smells like 50 top 40 radio stations blasting at once. Mons laboratory. Smells like an orchestra of raw possibilities. Composed of both natural and synthetic ingredients.
数百种香调中的几滴混合在一起。实验室里的气味太不可思议了。它不像百货公司的香水柜台。那种地方闻起来就像同时播放着50首公告牌热门单曲。曼恩的实验室。闻起来就像一个充满原始可能性的管弦乐队。由天然和合成成分组成。
And without derailing this whole story, let me just say there are some controversies in there. Perfume ingredients are considered trade secrets, so they aren't listed on the bottle, and this opacity has caused some worry, because there are ingredients, natural and synthetic alike, that can trigger allergic reactions, and some animal studies have found fragrance chemicals that are probable carcinogens, or have been linked to liver, kidney, and lung damage. The perfume industry says that all the ingredients
而且在不偏离整个故事主题的前提下，我只想说其中存在一些争议。香水成分被视为商业机密，因此它们不会列在瓶子上，这种不透明性引起了一些担忧，因为有些成分，无论是天然的还是合成的，都可能引发过敏反应，并且一些动物实验发现香水化学物质可能是可能的致癌物，或者与肝脏、肾脏和肺部损伤有关。香水行业表示，他们使用的所有成分
they use are at such low concentration that they aren't dangerous to human health. But there have been calls to set more limits on materials perfumers can use. And sure enough, every now and then, an ingredient gets pulled off the market. I look at it as if they're doing some kind of testing with the ingredients and they're being a little restrictive,
浓度都非常低，不会对人类健康构成危险。但一直有人呼吁对调香师可以使用的材料设定更多限制。果不其然，每隔一段时间，就会有一种成分被撤出市场。我认为，如果他们对成分进行某种测试并且有一点限制性，
I think there's some value to that, if it's gonna help humanity in some way. It ties my hands a little bit on trying to be creative. Gino is operating within a set of constantly shifting constraints. Instruments are being removed from Man's orchestra all the time. By the different regulatory laws of every country, yes, but also by an ingredients availability.
如果这能在某种程度上帮助人类，我觉得这还是有一定价值的。这让我在试图发挥创造力时有点束手束脚。吉诺是在一套不断变化的限制条件内运作的。曼恩的管弦乐队中的乐器一直在被移除。是的，通过每个国家的不同的监管法律，还有因为成分的可用性。
When a certain scent becomes trendy, it becomes harder to procure. Take Indian sandalwood. It's a delicious natural scent, super popular. There's a drop of Indian sandalwood and pretty much everything on the market. And the challenge with Indian sandalwood is that the trees have to be at least 30 years old before you can harvest them. You can't just go plant more trees and have more oil tomorrow. You've got to wait 30 years. So Indian sandalwood had to be replaced with Australian sandalwood,
当某种气味变得流行时，它就更难采购了。以印度檀香为例。这是一种美妙的天然香气，超级受欢迎。市场上几乎所有东西里都有一滴印度檀香。而印度檀香的挑战在于，树木必须至少生长30年才能采伐。你不能只是去种更多的树，明天就能有更多的油。你得等30年。所以印度檀香不得不被澳大利亚檀香所取代，
which doesn't smell the same, or with synthetic sandalwood, which doesn't smell the same, or with synthetic sandalwood, which doesn't smell the same. So making a new perfume isn't just unbridled creativity. It's limited by a lot of factors. And at the end of the day, the scent has to sell. Mom's brilliant perfumers probably aren't going to make something that smells like fig and szechuan peppers. They manufacture pop music. They're trying to make something interesting within the parameters of mainstream taste,
或者用闻起来不一样的合成檀香，或者用闻起来不一样的合成檀香，或者用闻起来不一样的合成檀香。所以制作一款新香水不仅仅是肆无忌惮的创造力。它受到很多因素的限制。归根结底，这款香水必须卖得出去。曼恩出色的调香师们可能不会做出闻起来像无花果和四川花椒的东西。他们制造的是流行音乐。他们试图在主流品味的参数范围内制造出有趣的东西，
something you'd buy in a Sephora, or something you'd buy in your grocery store. Because man, and the dozen or so major fragrance companies don't just make perfume. They work on every product that has a smell. Home care, cleaning laundry, personal care. Suzanne McCormick is a head of fragrance for method products. They make soap and detergent and body wash and they work with two of the major fragrance houses. Because I kid you not, it is just the same small handful of companies that are crafting all the sense all around us. And this overlap means that trends in high-end perfume affect your dish soap.
你在丝芙兰买得到的，或者你在杂货店买得到的东西。因为曼恩以及其他十几家主要的香水公司不仅仅制造香水。他们参与了所有有气味的产品。家居护理、清洁洗衣、个人护理。苏珊娜·麦考密克（Suzanne McCormick）是Method Products公司的香水负责人。他们生产肥皂、洗涤剂和沐浴露，并与两家主要的香水公司合作。因为我没开玩笑，就是这同一小撮公司在为我们周围的所有产品调制各种气味。这种重叠意味着高端香水的趋势会影响到你的洗洁精。
There is a trickle down. It's just like how high-end fashion designers will create a look that eventually ends up at H&M. If a fragrance company develops an accord that sells really well, that scent might eventually end up in your face cream or your laundry detergent. Rose had been considered the older fragrance note, and then many fine fragrance brands were bringing it to life in a modern way. And then as you trickle down to our body wash, we have a penny, rose water. And a while back, there was sea salt and everything. So we did lime and sea salt was one of our fragrances that we did that's continued to do
这是一种自上而下的传导。就像高端时装设计师会设计出一款造型，最终流传到H&M一样。如果一家香水公司开发出一种卖得很好的香协，这种气味最终可能会出现在你的面霜或洗衣液中。玫瑰曾被认为是一种较老的香水调，然后许多高级香水品牌以现代的方式将其复活。接着，当你向下传导到我们的沐浴露时，我们有了牡丹、玫瑰水。前段时间，到处都是海盐。所以我们做了青柠和海盐，这是我们制作的香水之一，并且一直做得
very well. And so these scent companies are everywhere making you your kitchen and your bathroom smell like citrus and lavender and rose. But this idea of our bodies smelling somewhat interchangeably with our fabric softener and our dishes is relatively recent. We used to have a wildly different concept of what it meant to smell good. I guess I could start with the perfumes that shocked me the most and they were the perfumes of the 20s, 30s and 40s. Barbara Herman is the creative director of
非常好。因此，这些香水公司无处不在，让你的厨房和浴室闻起来像柑橘、薰衣草和玫瑰。但这种我们的身体气味与我们的织物柔软剂和餐具气味有些互换的想法是相对近期的。我们过去对“闻起来很香”有着截然不同的概念。我想我可以从那些最让我震惊的香水开始，它们是20、30和40年代的香水。芭芭拉·赫尔曼（Barbara Herman）是
Eris Parfum and the author of the book, Sent and Subversion. I like to describe what I did in this book was sniff my way through the 20th century. What we think people should smell like is completely cultural, and it's changed over time. In the 1920s, 30s and 40s, women were marketed perfumes that were
Eris Parfum的创意总监，也是《气味与颠覆》（Scent and Subversion）一书的作者。我喜欢这样描述我在书中所做的事情：嗅着气味走过整个20世纪。我们认为人们应该闻起来像什么完全是文化使然，而且它随时间而改变。在20世纪20、30和40年代，女性被推销的香水是
more funky. Women smelled like tobacco and leather, and, you know, as Jacques Garland said about his perfumes, perfumes should smell like the underside of my mistress. There was this idea that perfume was supposed to smell funky. Perfumes had ingredients like ambergree, which is oxidized whale vomit, and musk, which is deer sex gland secretion. Now these kinds of smells are made synthetically, but in the early 20th century, people wore the real stuff, which sounds off-putting,
更加不羁的。女性闻起来有烟草和皮革的味道，而且，正如雅克·娇兰（Jacques Guerlain）对他的香水的评价一样，香水应该闻起来像我情妇的下体。当时有一种观点认为，香水就应该闻起来有些不羁。香水的成分包括龙涎香（属于氧化后的鲸鱼呕吐物）和麝香（属于鹿的性腺分泌物）。现在这些气味都是人工合成的，但在20世纪初，人们用的是真品，这听起来让人反感，
but actually, these smells are fascinating. Barbara happened to have some real ambergree in her refrigerator. I mean, it's very very hard sentence to describe. Some people say there's tobacco note, there's obviously a very animalic kind of equal quality to it, but also slightly metallic and chrysanthemum or like hay like slightly sweet. It's more of a feeling than it is a smell for me. It's just like being enveloped in warmth. I loved this smell. I'm like looking at a landscape through a pinhole.
但实际上，这些气味令人着迷。芭芭拉碰巧在冰箱里有一些真正的龙涎香。我是说，这是一种非常非常难描述的气味。有些人说有一种烟草香调，显然有一种非常动物性的等效品质，但也略带金属味和菊花味，或者像干草般略带甜味。对我来说，这与其说是一种气味，不如说是一种感觉。就像被温暖包裹着一样。我喜欢这种气味。我感觉就像通过一个小孔在看风景。
Oh, can I see more of it? Yeah, that's a weird way to describe it. I wish I could stick my head in a box full. Yeah, it's very evocated. Yeah. For all those weird and gross descriptors, amber grease smells incredible. Most sense, especially naturally occurring ones, are way more nuanced and strange than we'd like to believe. There's a sweetness and sweat, a fruiting-ness and blood. I know I sound like a psychopath, but there's a really fuzzy line between delicious and off-putting. If you pay attention to your nose and forget the fact that this may be well-barked.
哦，我能看更多吗？是的，这是一种奇怪的描述方式。我真想把头伸进装满这种东西的箱子里。是的，太有唤起力了。是的。对于所有这些奇怪和恶心的描述，龙涎香闻起来棒极了。大多数气味，尤其是自然发生的气味，比我们想象的要微妙和奇怪得多。甜味中夹杂着汗水，果香中夹杂着血腥。我知道我听起来像个精神病患者，但在美味和令人反感之间，有一条非常模糊的界限。如果你关注你的鼻子，忘掉这个东西可能带有臭味的事实。
Because it's sensual and cozy and a lot of, you know, subliminal unconscious effects. I can't put them all into words, but if you've experienced them and if you open to them, you'll know exactly what I'm talking about. And it's interesting that people in the 1920s, 30s and 40s were more willing to wear these strong, animalic smells. It's particularly interesting that they were marketed to women.
因为它是感官的、舒适的，而且有很多，你知道的，潜意识的影响。我无法用语言把它们全部表达出来，但如果你体验过它们并且对它们持开放态度，你就会完全明白我在说什么。有趣的是，20世纪20、30和40年代的人们更愿意穿戴这些强烈的动物性气味。特别有趣的是，它们是专门针对女性进行营销的。
On the one hand, it's kind of empowering and bold and sensuous, but I also meant these women weren't exactly dousing themselves to go to board meetings. These were cents for the bedroom. And our idea of what femininity should smell like evolved in the 1950s when a lot of bright and powdery cents came out. Very like Doris Day Peppy.
一方面，这有点赋权、大胆和感性，但这也意味着这些女性并不是为了去开董事会而把香水喷满全身的。这些是卧室里的香水。我们对女性气质应该闻起来像什么的看法在20世纪50年代发生了演变，当时涌现出许多明亮粉香的气味。非常像多莉丝·戴（Doris Day）那种活泼的风格。
Florals, huge ass, white, florals, screaming. And then, like everything else in culture, scent was subverted by the time you get to the 70s, when there was this natural wave of okmas and patchouli. Then the 1980s were about big bold fragrances, the kind that, as Rachel Sim puts it, could clear an elevator. And then, there was a very important pendulum swing in the 1990s.
花香，巨大的、白色的、尖叫的花香。然后，就像文化中的其他一切一样，到了70年代，气味被颠覆了，当时涌现出一股由橡苔和广藿香组成的自然浪潮。接下来的80年代则是宏大、大胆的香水的天下，正如蕾切尔·西姆（Rachel Sim）所说，那种能让电梯清空的气味。然后，在90年代发生了一次非常重要的钟摆摆动。
A sea change that mainstream sensibilities have still not recovered from. The 90s was generally the clean decade. This is when perfumes like CK1 came out for men and for women. There was this wave of clean smells that were light and fresh and inoffensive. They made you smell like you just showered. Yeah, I mean there's
这是一场主流审美至今尚未恢复过来的沧海桑田般的巨变。90年代通常被称为“干净的十年”。这就是CK1等男女皆宜的香水问世的时候。当时涌现出一股干净气味的浪潮，它们轻盈、清新且不具攻击性。它们让你闻起来就像刚刚洗过澡一样。是的，我的意思是
some great clean perfumes. Like don't get me wrong, I love to rag on them, but I just think that what perfume meant in the past and what it means now is very different. Clean sense took off in a major way. Exceedingly popular, a lot of money in them. And when perfume just became kind of generally pleasant and non-threatening, more and more companies felt comfortable yoking their prize brand name to it. Industrial perfume creation world, which happened
有些非常棒的干净香水。别误会我的意思，我喜欢取笑它们，但我只是认为香水过去意味着什么和现在意味着什么有很大不同。干净的气味以巨大的方式兴起。极其受欢迎，其中蕴含着巨额资金。当香水变得普遍令人愉快且没有威胁性时，越来越多的公司觉得可以放心地将他们宝贵的品牌名称与之绑定。工业香水创造世界，这发生在
like after the 90s or starting in the 90s, when perfumes just got like, mass produced, celebrity scent thing. And so broadly speaking, we are still stuck there in the fresh and clean era, particularly the United States. Oh, we're Puritans, really? Yeah, to smell was to be sensual or to be erotic or dirty. That's why fresh and clean is such a big deal in this country. Miranda Gordon at Monaghan.
90年代之后或从90年代开始，当时香水变得就像大批量生产的名人香水一样。所以总的来说，我们仍然卡在那个清新干净的时代，特别是在美国。哦，我们真是清教徒？是的，有气味就等于感官、色情或肮脏。这就是为什么清新和干净在这个国家如此重要。曼恩的米兰达·戈登。
In France, you're sexy if you're a little funky. Here, you've got to be freshly showered and smell like nothing. And in fact, if you do want to smell like nothing at all, that also involves fragrance. Because even when you're buying a product labeled fragrance-free, that is often not true. The product that's labeled fragrance-free in all likelihood remained a customer of ours, and we had to fragrance it in order to cover up the maloters of the functional things in your products. There's probably something in there that's what we call a masking or a masking aroma that's canceling out whatever fishy smell or funky
在法国，如果你有点不羁，你就是性感的。在这里，你必须刚洗过澡，而且闻起来像什么都没有。事实上，如果你真的想闻起来什么都没有，那也需要用到香水。因为即使当你购买标有“无香精”的产品时，这通常也不是真的。那个被标为“无香精”的产品，极有可能仍然是我们公司的客户，我们必须为它添加香精，以掩盖你产品中功能性成分带来的异味。里面可能有一些我们称之为掩蔽香气的东西，用来消除你的面霜中成分可能具有的任何鱼腥味、怪味或真正的气味。
smell or really smell the ingredients in your face cream might have. Because most things on this earth have a smell. It's just that an industry has developed around avoiding the weird ones. We want to smell fresh and clean and nothing else. And so, yeah, the mainstream perfume market's been stuck in the clean boom for some decades now. But there's been a quiet revolution in the last 15-ish years on the fringes of perfume. An indie scene has blossomed. Okay, so now we're going to smell tomato leather. An indie scene has blossomed. Okay, so now we're going to smell tomato leather.
因为地球上的大多数东西都有气味。只是围绕着避开那些奇怪的气味，已经发展出了一个产业。我们想要闻起来清新干净，除此之外别无他物。所以，是的，主流香水市场几十年来一直卡在干净的气味大热中。但在过去的15年左右里，在香水的外围发生了一场静悄悄的革命。一个独立香水界已经蓬勃发展。好了，现在我们要闻番茄皮革。一个独立香水界已经蓬勃发展。好了，现在我们要闻番茄皮革。
This is meant to be literally a combination of those two smells. At her San Francisco perfume store, Tiger Lily, Antonio Cole sells sense that are deeply, deeply odd. This fragrance is inspired by the printmaker's studio and by India Inc. Inspired by the god of the afterlife in Egypt. And the smell she imagined would be inside the tunes. This is what smells like when you're waiting for the ferry to take you to Seattle. There's so many more unusual sense in the store.
这字面意思就是这两种气味的结合。在安东尼娅·科尔（Antonio Cole）位于旧金山的香水店“百合”（Tiger Lily）里，她出售着气味极其、极其古怪的香水。这款香是以版画艺术家的工作室和印度墨水为灵感的。灵感来自埃及的冥界之神。以及她想象中陵墓内部的气味。这就是当你等待渡轮带你去西雅图时闻到的气味。店里有更多不寻常的气味。
We've got stuff that smells like campfires and... Ooh. Thousands of independent perfumers have started popping up. Many of them taking artistic risks that a designer brand wouldn't dare attempt. There are hard core boutiques, like Tiger Lily, scattered around the world. And they almost act like oddball record shops
我们有闻起来像营地篝火的东西，还有……哦。成千上万的独立调香师开始涌现。他们中的许多人冒着设计师品牌绝不敢尝试的艺术风险。世界各地散落着像“百合”这样硬核的精品店。它们几乎就像是为地下音乐书呆子准备的古怪唱片店，满足那些想要嗅探奇异东西的人。它字面意思闻起来就像蝙蝠洞。这就像一种强烈的潮土气息（petricor），你能感觉到洞穴中泥土和石头上的水。然后它也代表了果蝠生命中的一天。所以你还会闻到掉落的水果，比如腐烂的香蕉，你还会闻到
for the underground music nerds who want to sniff the strange stuff. It literally smells like a bat's cave. It's like a strong petricor with where you feel the water on the dirt and the stone in the cave. And then it also represents, it's a day in the life of a fruit bat. So you also get the fallen fruit like rotting banana and you get a
代表蝙蝠翅膀的皮革味。在这个相对崭新的运动中，有很多调香师把做香水当成副业和激情项目。制作蝙蝠香水的调香师就是这种情况。她有一份正职。她同时也是一名蝙蝠行为科学家。真的吗？还是一位真正的兰花种植者。所以是的，她在华盛顿大学教授行为科学，并且专攻蝙蝠。她业余时间还做香水。是的。哇。并且还为此获得了奖项。正当我跟安东尼娅在“百合”的奇珍异宝柜台周围嗅闻时，一个顾客气喘吁吁地冲了进来。
leather that represents the batswing. In this relatively new movement, there are a lot of perfumers who make scent on the side as a passion project. That's the case for the perfumer who made the bat scent. She has a day job. She's also a bat behavioral scientist. Really? And a really orchid farmer. So yes, she teaches at the University of Washington in the behavioral sciences and she specializes in bats. And she does perfume on the side. Yeah. Wow. And wins awards for it. As Antonia and I sniffed around Tiger Lillie's cabinet of curiosities, a customer rushed in breathlessly.
嗨！嗨！你好吗？我知道你是来找什么的。我不是。说他们疯了吧。毛里西奥（Mauricio）我想在后面帮你留着呢。这位顾客在寻找一款小众香水，这款香水曾一度暂停生产，因为……这位调香师同时也是一位网络安全专家，他有了一份新工作，刚刚升职了。所以他太忙了，没法再生产了，所以她今天打电话来说还有剩下的吗？人们对香水的反应非常强烈。这是一件情绪化的事情，不仅对“百合”的那位顾客如此。我们所有人的大脑对它都是天生敏感的。
Hi! Hi! how are you doing? I know what you're here for. I'm not. Call them crazy. And Mauricio, I think, has it for you in the back. This customer was looking for a niche scent that had been put on hiatus because... The perfume also is a cyber security expert and it has a new job just got promoted. And so he's so busy, he can't make any more of it so she called today and was like to have any left. People have really strong reactions to perfume. It's an emotional thing and it's not just for that customer at Tiger Lily. We're all wired for it.
你把这些分子吸进来。它们与受体结合。再次听到莫内尔化学感官中心的帕梅拉·达尔顿（Pamela Dalton）的声音。这个信号穿过大脑中被称为边缘系统的一部分，该系统负责情绪反应。所以正是这种情绪反应与我们正在闻到的东西紧密地联系在了一起。当我去参加大学同学聚会时，我惊讶地发现我以前的宿舍走廊闻起来还是老样子。
You sniff these molecules in. They bind to a receptor. Pamela Dalton from the Monal Chemical Senses Center again. That signal is passing through a portion of the brain called the limbic system which is responsible for emotional responses. So it's that emotional response that becomes so tightly associated with something that we're smelling. When I went to my college reunion, I was struck that my old dorm hallway still smelled the same.
一阵佛手柑的气味总是让我想起前任。桉树味把我带回了小时候去旧金山探望奶奶的旅行。我们都有这种超能力，可以将气味用作通往过去的门户。但在学习闻香和学习谈论气味的过程中，我们可以体验到生动的现在。停下来闻闻玫瑰花香，当然，但也停下来闻闻垃圾的气味。真的，在沙发上，在走廊里，在洗发水中，在橘子皮里，在汗水和雨水中，在丰富和砖头里
A wafed of bergamot always reminds me of an ex. Eucalyptus brings me back to childhood trips to visit my grandma in San Francisco. We all have this superpower to use scent as a gateway to the past. But in learning to smell and learning to talk about smell, we can experience a vivid present. To stop and smell the roses, sure, but also stop and smell the garbage. Really, in the couch, in the hallway, in the shampoo, and the skin of a mandarin, the sweat and the rain and the plethora and the brick
去闻闻你现在所在的地方。我想很多人会说：我不喜欢香水，我对它毫无兴趣。我第一次见到蕾切尔·西姆（Rachel Sim）是在联合广场的那家丝芙兰。我就是那些人之一。对我来说，我想，哇，我认为这是一种艺术形式，我对其着迷不已，我热爱人们所创造的东西，甚至在这里我也喜欢探索各种不同的创作，这就是为什么我会买瓶子里的东西，因为那是某人创造的东西。这就像买艺术品。第二次见到蕾切尔时，她给了我一小瓶香水。
to smell where you are right now. I think a lot of people are like, I don't like perfume, I have no interest in it. The first time I met Rachel Sim and that's Sephora in Union Square. I was one of those people. And for me, I'm like, wow, I think it's an art form and I'm fasting it by an endlessly and I love what people make and even here I just love exploring all different creations and that's why I'd buy something in a bottle because it's something somebody made. It's like buying art. The second time I saw Rachel, she gave me a little bottle of perfume.
她警告我，这是那种你在丝芙兰买不到的东西。瓶子很朴素，这个品牌我从未听说过。第一口（应为第一嗅，译者按语境意译）闻起来很舒适，有雪松和皮革味。就像骑着摩托车穿过树林。再闻一下，它闻起来像汽油，实际上让人作呕，差点让我头疼。我把这个气味搁置了好几个月。但最近我又回来闻了闻，
She warned me it was the kind of thing you couldn't get her to Sephora. The bottle was plain, I had never heard of the brand. At first sniff it was cozy, cedar and leather. It was riding on the back of a motorcycle through the woods. Another sniff and it smelled like gasoline and it was actually sickening, it nearly gave me a headache. I abandoned the scent for months. But recently came back and smelled again, and
这一次它散发出一种麦芽的香气，几乎有点像太妃糖（score-moned，译者注：可能指toffee或某种焦糖）。我说不上来。它随我的心情而改变。它随我的皮肤而改变。它随我的日子、我的周围环境、天气以及我周围基本上被我大部分忽略的气味交响乐而改变。口袋里，那张纸，来自昨天的文字。来自昨天的文字。在我们所爱的事物上画着一幅肖像。
this time something malted came out of it, almost score-moned. I can't pin it down. It changes with my mood. It changes with my skin. It changes with my day, with my surroundings, and the weather, and the cacophony of smells all around me that I buy and large. Used to ignore. The pocket, the piece of paper, words from yesterday. Words from yesterday. There's a portrait painted on the things we love. Articles of Interest was written and performed by Avery Truffelman, edited by Chris Berube, with additional edits by Joe Rosenberg and Emmett Fitzgerald, scored by Ray Royal, fact-checked
《感兴趣的物件》由艾瑞·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffelman）编剧并演播，克里斯·伯鲁比（Chris Berube）剪辑，乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）和埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）协助剪辑，雷·罗亚尔（Ray Royal）配乐，汤姆·科利根（Tom Colligan）核实事实，格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Haysha）协助核实事实，混音和技术制作由谢里夫·乌塞夫（Sharifusev）完成，凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Catherine Ray Mondo）协助混音。我们的开场和闭幕曲由苏萨米（Susami）创作。特别感谢本集的调香师曼迪·阿夫塔尔（Mandy Aftal）、香水评论家钱德勒·伯尔（Chandler Burr）、香水瓶设计师查德·莱文（Chad Levine）、曼恩公司的达娜·布鲁诺（Dana Bruno），尤其是曼恩公司的维维·普罗沃（Vivi Provo）。感谢整个99%无形（99% Invisible）团队提供的深刻支持和剪辑，包括维维安·勒（Vivian Le）、肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial）、艾比·马丹（Abby Madan）、库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstead）、德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）和凯蒂·明格（Katie Mingle）。罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）是整个系列清新干净的气味。
by Tom Colligan with additional fact-checking by Graham Haysha, Mix and Tech Production by Sharifusev with additional mixing by Catherine Ray Mondo. Our opening and closing songs are by Susami. Special thanks to this episode to Master Perfumer Mandy Aftal, Perfume critic Chandler Burr, Perfume bottle designer Chad Levine, Dana Bruno at Man, and especially Vivi Provo at Man. Insight support and edits from the whole 99PIT, including Vivian Le, Sean Rial, Abby Madan, Kurt Colstead, Delaney Hall, and Katie Mingle. And Roman Mars is the fresh and clean scent of this whole series.
事物之下的画作是一幅肖像。香水中的性别就像社会中的性别一样，是一个人为的社会构建。曼恩的营销副总裁米兰达·戈登说：从来没有人说过花只属于女孩，或者其实我们说过，行业是这么说的，但我不知道全球是否同意花属于女孩而木头属于男孩。某种性别不应该只有一种特定的气味，因为我们大家闻起来都差不多像是我们的皮肤和汗水。
There's a portrait of painting of things below. Gender in fragrance is as artificial as social construct as gender in society. Amen Miranda Gordon, VP of Marketing at Mon. Nobody ever said that flowers were only for girls or actually we did say the industry said, but I don't know that the globe agrees that flowers are for girls and woods are for boys. There's no way a given gender is supposed to smell, because we all just kind of smell like our skin and sweat.
古龙水和香水之间的区别仅仅在于精油的浓度。并不是说古龙水比香水更有男子气概。这只是营销方式的问题。过去男人和女人都会使用大量的香水，通常是为了掩盖他们不洗澡的事实。直到一个男人决定香水是属于女性的。但在那过程中，他也决定每天洗澡，
The distinction between cologne and perfume is just about the concentration of oil. It's not that cologne is any more masculine than perfume. It's just the way it's marketed. Men and women both used to wear a lot of perfume usually to mask the fact that they didn't bathe. Until one man decided that perfume was for women. But in the course of that, he also would bathe every day,
这在当时（18世纪后期）被认为是一种相当荒谬的虚荣，甚至洗澡这么频繁可能会对你的健康有害。这是作家伊恩·凯利（Ian Kelly）说的。他说，曾有这样一位历史上的绅士，他规定男人的气味应该尽可能朴素。事实上，他还认为男人的穿着应该尽可能朴素，认为有男子气概就是看起来无聊。
which was taken at the time, the late 18th century, as a rather ridiculous vanity, and indeed, something that might be even dangerous for your health to wash that often. That's author Ian Kelly. And he says there was this one historic gentleman who decreed that men should smell as plain as possible. In fact, he also thought men should dress as plain as possible, that to be manly was to look boring.
他，是的，恰好在正确的时间成为了处于这种时尚转变中心的那个人。你下一个感兴趣的物件是西装。目前还没有这一集的评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。
He, yes, happened to be the right person at the right time to be the center of this some shift in fashion. Your next articles of interest are suits. be the center of this some shift in fashion. Your next articles of interest are suits. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他，是的，恰好在对的时间成为了对的人，成为时尚转型的中心。您接下来感兴趣的文章是西装。目前本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。